Off.
Quand Kepler observait l’obscurité du ciel
la nuit, il y voyait la finitude de l’univers.
En effet, si l’univers était infini et
s’il y avait des étoiles un peu partout
dans l’univers, alors, quelque soit la direction
dans laquelle on regarde, notre regard devrait
croiser l’une des étoiles de l’univers.
Cependant, les cosmologistes modernes y voient
autre chose.
Pour les cosmologistes modernes, l’obscurité
du ciel révèle la finitude de son âge.
Avant de commencer, il me faut vous parler
de formule 1.
Vous l’entendez ? C’est l’effet Doppler.
Off.
Considérons une source avec un signal très
régulier.
Si je ne bouge pas par rapport à la source,
je l’entends à la bonne fréquence.
Un tic par seconde.
Off.
Vous l’entendez ? Quand la source se rapproche
de moi, les tics que j’entends sont plus
fréquents.
Pour comprendre pourquoi, notez que les tics
ont différentes origines spatiales.
Et vous voyez que les fronts d’onde sont
alors rapprochés.
À l’inverse, quand la source s’éloigne,
les tics sont moins fréquents.
Off.
En terme de sons, les signaux de fréquences
plus petites correspondent à du son plus
grave.
Et ça, ça veut dire que le son de sources
qui s’éloignent de nous APPARAISSENT PLUS
GRAVES que si l’on ne bougeait pas par rapport
aux sources.
C’est ce que l’on appelle l’effet doppler.
Et plus la source d’un son va vite, plus
l’effet Doppler est grand.
Et ça, ça explique le son des formules 1.
Aïgu, grave.
Les formules 1 vont très vite.
Et l’effet Doppler est donc énorme pour
elles.
Et c’est en fait grâce à la mesure de
l’effet de Doppler de ma voiture, que j’ai
reçu une prune…
Off.
Ce phénomène qui s’applique au son s’applique
à la lumière aussi, même si l’explication
physique est un peu différente.
Mais au lieu de rendre le son plus grave,
l’effet Doppler fait paraître la lumière
des sources qui s’éloignent de nous plus
rouge.
C’est ce que l’on appelle… le décalage
vers le rouge.
Dans les années 1930, Lemaître et Hubble
ont observé ce décalage vers le rouge pour
les galaxies lointaines.
Qui plus est, ils remarquèrent que plus les
galaxies étaient lointaines, plus grand était
le décalage vers le rouge.
Les galaxies lointaines subissent un plus
grand effet de Doppler.
Lemaître et Hubble conclurent alors que les
galaxies lointaines s’éloignaient plus
vite que les galaxies proches.
C’est ce que l’on appelle la loi de Hubble.
En fait, la loi de Hubble dit un peu plus
que cela.
Elle dit que la vitesse à laquelle une galaxie
s’éloigne de nous est proportionnelle à
la distance qui la sépare de nous.
Off.
De façon cruciale, en remontant le temps,
ceci implique que toute la matière originait
d’un point unique.
En fait, en combinant la thermodynamique,
la mécanique quantique et la relativité
générale, Lemaître en vint à affirmer
que notre univers tout entier était, il y
a très longtemps, un unique quantum d’énergie.
Un atome primitif.
Un Big Bang.
Et bien sûr, tout le monde était d’accord
avec Lemaître…
En fait.
Non.
Plusieurs contemporains de Lemaître, y compris
Hubble, arguaient que le fait que l’univers
soit en expansion n’impliquaient pas que
celui-ci avait une origine.
What ?
J’imagine que beaucoup de physiciens à
cette époque adoraient l’idée d’un univers
statique et éternel.
Mais bien sûr, il y a une autre raison plus
“rationnelle” à leur confusion.
Off.
Les calculs de Hubble suggéraient que l’expansion
de l’univers avait commencé il y a 2 milliards
d’années… ce qui est super étrange,
sachant que les analyses des particules radioactives
indiquaient que la Terre était âgée d’au
moins 4,5 milliards d’années.
Comment l’univers peut-il être plus jeune
que ce qu’il contient ? Y a-t-il une sorte
d’effet de dilatation du temps qui accélère
le temps sur Terre ?
Non.
Les calculs de Hubble étaient en fait faux.
Mais personne ne le savait…
Off.
C’est pourquoi, en 1948, quand le physicien
Fred Hoyle prouva que, en supposant une création
spontanée, continue mais extrêmement rare
de matière, l’univers pouvait être à
la fois statique et en expansion éternelle,
beaucoup de personnes furent convaincu.
Après tout, il avait entre ses mains une
théorie de l’espace-temps qui étaient
en accord à la fois avec la loi d’Hubble,
l’âge de la Terre et toutes les observations
faites à l’époque.
Du coup, tout le monde crut Hoyle.
Et tout le monde oublia Lemaître.
Cependant, de nouveaux arguments en faveur
de la théorie du Big Bang virent le jour
dans un tout autre domaine de la physique.
Off.
À la fin des années 40, les experts de la
physique nucléaire était complètement déconcerté
par l’abondance des éléments légers comme
l’hydrogène et l’hélium, malgré l’absence
de mécanismes naturels pour les produire.
Alpher et d’autres remarquèrent alors que
cette abondance pouvait être très bien expliquée
si l’univers avait connu une phase très
dense et fabuleusement énergétique.
Ce serait pendant cette phase que les atomes
légers auraient été produit en très grande
quantité.
Durant cette phase, l’univers aurait alors
été une soupe primordiale chaude et lumineuse.
Mais Fred Hoyle rétorqua que si cette phase
avait existé, elle serait encore visible
dans le ciel.
Mais les observateurs avaient beau regarder
le ciel aussi longtemps qu’ils le voulaient.
Le ciel, la nuit, était, et est encore noir…
Et les idées d’Alpher furent oubliées…
Off.
Des décennies plus tard, en 1965, Dicke et
Peebles redécouvrirent les idées d’Alpher.
Mais entre-temps, les technologies avaient
amélioré les performances de vision nocturnes
si bien que Dicke et Peebles espéraient qu’ils
pourraient détecter la soupe primordiale
que leur théorie du Big Bang prédisait.
Et ils savaient que s’ils détectaient cette
soupe primordiale, ils feraient ainsi l’une
des plus grandes découvertes de l’Histoire
des sciences.
Off.
Ils reçurent alors un coup de fil…
Dicke écouta, se retourna vers Peebles et
s’exclama…
On s’est fait devancé !
Off.
Par accident, les observateurs Penzias et
Wilson avaient détecté ce qu’ils pensaient
être un bruit dérangeant qui venait de toutes
les directions.
Après avoir suspecté des nids de pigeons
dans leurs antennes, Penzias et Wilson se
rendirent compte que ce bruit correspondait
exactement à la soupe primordiale qu’Alpher
avait prédit des décennies plus tôt.
Off.
Notre ciel est lumineux.
Incroyablement lumineux.
Mais l’expansion astronomique de notre univers
avait créé un effet de Doppler massif qui
avait décalé vers le rouge la lumière de
la soupe primordiale.
Et l’avait rendu infrarouge.
Si infrarouge que nos yeux ne sont pas capables
de la voir.
Aujourd’hui, cette lumière très brillante,
mais très décalée vers le rouge, est ce
que l’on appelle le fond diffus cosmologique
ou rayonnement fossile.
Et c’est l’observation qui a fait triomphé
la théorie du Big Bang.
Et je pense que c’est incroyablement cool.
Quand on lève nos yeux au ciel.
Nos yeux capturent des photons qui ont traversé
l’univers tout entier, juste pour nous donner
un aperçu des premiers
instants
de notre espace-temps…